hi guys I'm Greg hi guys I'm John we're
gonna be watching a video from Logan
Logan he called you know the drill
I know the drill ADA miss Martha you
understand you're trespassing right now
right I have an evening with the
previous one with your property previous
being the operative word
it was this the guy could either get
back in your nice truck let's go play
okie big head tomorrow mm-hmm I call
looks like mr. Martin Harris and muscle
looks that way it's a friend of mine
friend with a big mouth I hear that a
lot you probably hear this too more than
I'd like
and you know the drill little count
three and you're gonna start walking
away hair like this one have a lawyer
now 203 nice ya know the drill
good Alan Oh nipple chills
this'll chill slight slight nipple chill
I wonder if that really pertains to the
full scope of the film yeah I'm curious
I don't know what that's about I hope
the whole film revolves around
Logan having to protect this one
location that he's at and it's about his
friendship with this black man yeah well
nothing to do with x-23 nothing with
Professor X dying and all that
I think the palaca mainly focus here I'd
watch a whole movie just based off that
well I've always said that what we
really really need from Wolverine is a
heartwarming male bonding tale and
that's what I think we got behind which
job yeah about time we got that this
does seem to have that tone though that
they keep talking about how that western
town oh yeah ever really feels like out
of a Western scene
then will moment yeah southern accents
and all beyond that though the whole
kind of slow-moving tension building
kind of yet arrived I really
enjoy that that was the word I was gonna
use to is like tension like I didn't
quite know exactly where that scene was
going and he when he breaks the gun in
half way has a great moment like you
snatched her right out of guys hands
like totally takes done it's about how
to throw down crazy
yeah I do that too whenever she was a
gun I mean I just snap it in half break
it from them I am that strong
I can I can squat a hundred pounds do it
it's crazy do you like break the gun
with your feet I like to put it
underneath my knee and it just squeeze
yeah it snaps in half that's why I like
that is important you can't skip like
day everyone can't skip like day because
like day is the day that boosts your
metabolism and more importantly it makes
you bulletproof yeah if there's anything
to be taken away from from any Logan or
Wolverine based movie it's that you
should wear newly advertised scaly like
day hamstrings calves all those are the
most important muscles you don't even
need to do upper body no I never it
doesn't really come in hand if you
really want to build your biceps and
chef squat well this is our Thoreau
Logan clip review whereas you guys you
know the drill
you know the drill sarcasm back with a
couple of opinions here's the channel
you can subscribe to the real rejects
Jon's reasons to Jerry on Twitter and
Instagram and he's a social media
manager abloom house and the real
rejects true and shout out to famke
janssen what's her name
funky Anson x-3x men the United at last
and is great I really feel that she was
very underrated yeah especially in the
third especially in house on Haunted
Hill Oh totally Geoffrey Rush's wife
dude Eliot is she she's the only
character I walked away remember yeah
and then that rollercoaster scene at the
beginning maybe got some fluffy is a
little bit it was mainly her because I
was like oh that's Jean Grey yeah and
she's totally gonna wig out and do some
Jean Grey she's like I never forgot that
rule